Krylovova kvantová diagonalizace neboli KQD označuje řešení problému maticových hodnot
projektováním matice do podprostoru připraveného na kvantovém počítači, což je v souladu s Krylovovou metodou –
mocným přístupem z klasické lineární algebry. V tomto videu prozkoumáme, k čemu je Krylovova metoda užitečná
a jak a kdy ji implementovat na kvantových počítačích.
Co je tedy Krylovova metoda? Předpokládejme, že máme matici H spojenou s nějakým vědeckým nebo obchodním problémem, která má n řádků a n
sloupců. Zajímá nás nejnižší vlastní hodnota e 0 a odpovídající vlastní vektor psi 0. Definujme
počáteční vektor v, který může být motivován strukturou h nebo může být zcela náhodný. Krylovův podprostor
řádu r, který zapisujeme jako k r, vznikne působením h na tento
počáteční vektor r minus jednou, přičemž výsledek každého dalšího působení h přidáváme
do množiny generujících vektorů. Kr je tedy prostor generovaný vektory v,
hv, h na druhou a tak dále. Tyto vektory obecně nebudou ortogonální.
Klasicky provádíme ortonormalizační proces velmi podobný Gram-Schmidtově postupu. Začneš
normalizací počátečního vektoru V a výsledek nazveš V 0. Poté pro další vektor HV odečteš jeho
projekci na V 0, aby byly oba vektory ortogonální. Výsledek pak normalizuješ. Takto pokračuješ dál,
znovu působíš H a výsledek děláš ortogonálním ke všem dříve přidaným vektorům, dokud nevybuduješ R
ortonormalizovaných vektorů potřebných k rozpětí tvého R-rozměrného Krylovova podprostoru.
Jakmile máš tento podprostor, projektituješ na něj matici a diagonalizuješ menší projektovanou matici. Existují
jemnější detaily a rozšíření, ale to je Krylovova metoda v té nejjednodušší podobě.
Abychom lépe pochopili, jak to funguje, podívejme se na triviální příklad. Pokud je H tato matice a V je zvolen jako tento
vektor, začneme normalizací V. Abychom vygenerovali druhý vektor v Krylovově podprostoru, působíme
jednou H na náš počáteční vektor a výsledek učiníme ortogonálním k V 0.
Malá algebra dá pro V1 tento výsledek.
Pro tak malé matice to není užitečné a obvykle bychom se nezastavili u Krylovovy dimenze dvě. Ale kdybychom
projektovali H na náš nový Krylovův prostor K2, použili bychom k tomu matici V,
která má Krylovův vektor v každém sloupci, a její transponovaný konjugát, který má Krylovovy vektory v řádcích. Poté bychom
získali tuto matici.
Tato matice má technicky nižší dimenzi než naše původní. Je zřejmé, že tato redukce v tomto
měřítku není užitečná. Tato metoda je určena pro redukci matic s mnoha tisíci nebo i miliony řádků a sloupců
na pouhý zlomek. Proč jsou tedy Krylovovy metody užitečné? Ukázalo se, že tento jednoduchý předpis
působení operátoru je často nejefektivnějším způsobem, jak se přiblížit ke stavu nejnižší hodnoty neboli základnímu stavu matice
a operátoru. Pojďme to trochu více upřesnit, i když úplný důkaz necháme na doprovodném textu. Chceme
vyřešit problém ve tvaru h působícího na vektor x, což nám dá nějakou konstantu násobenou vektorem x. Začněme s
odhadem našeho vlastního vektoru x0. Jde jen o přibližné řešení. Má chybu, kterou nazveme e 0. Chceme
aktualizovat tento odhad, který nazveme x1, a doufáme, že zlepší naši aproximaci. Můžeme to vyjádřit jako
původní x0 plus nějaká korekce p 0, která je zatím neurčená. Tento
proces můžeme opakovat iterativně, přidávaje stále více korekčních vektorů pi.
Samozřejmě chceme, aby se naše chyba zmenšovala, ale nejde jen o stav samotný. Záleží nám také na
působení h na tento stav. Veličina, kterou tedy chceme minimalizovat, je h-norma této chyby neboli norma
působení h na tuto chybu.
Nyní vidíme, že jde o výraz zahrnující p 0, a můžeme se ptát, jaká volba p minimalizuje
tuto h-normu chyby nejefektivněji. Z jakého prostoru bychom měli korekci vybírat? Za určitých
podmínek, například když je h symetrická a pozitivně definitní, je volba prvních r korekcí z kr
optimální. Jednoduše řečeno, potřebujeme nějaký způsob, jak připravit dobrý podprostor, na který
projektujeme náš Hamiltonián. A v mnoha případech je Krylovův podprostor prostor generovaný vektory nejefektivnějších
korekcí našeho počátečního odhadu.
Skutečný důkaz najdeš v textu doprovázejícím toto video.
Vše, co jsme dosud popsali, lze udělat klasicky. Jak a kdy bychom tedy použili kvantový počítač?
U velmi velkých matic může Krylovova metoda vyžadovat dlouhé výpočetní časy a velké množství paměti. Čas
potřebný pro operaci matice H na V roste v nejhorším případě jako N na druhou.
A to se děje pro každý vektor, který chceme v našem podprostoru. Dimenze podprostoru R obvykle není významnou
frakcí N a často roste jako logaritmus N. Takže generování všech vektorů roste
jako řád N^2 log N.
Ačkoliv existují další kroky jako ortonormalizace, toto je dominantní škálování, které je třeba mít na paměti.
Kvantové počítání nám umožňuje změnit to, jaké vlastnosti problému určují škálování času a zdrojů
potřebných pro výpočet. Namísto závislosti na velikosti matice n ve všech ohledech uvidíme věci jako počet shots a
počet nekomutujících Pauliho členů, ze kterých se skládá Hamiltonián.
Pojďme prozkoumat, jak to funguje.
Připomeň si, že operátor, který časově vyvíjí kvantový stav, je exponenciála iH přes h bar. A je
velmi běžné, zejména v kvantovém počítání, vynechat h bar z notace.
Jedním ze způsobů, jak pochopit a dokonce realizovat takovou exponenciální funkci operátoru, je podívat se na její Fourierovo
sériové rozvinutí. Všimni si, že tato operace působící na nějaký počáteční vektor V dává součet členů
WEBVTT
se stále vyššími mocninami H působícího na počáteční stav. Vypadá to, jako bychom mohli Krylovův podprostor vytvořit časovým vývojem
našeho počátečního stavu. A to je téměř pravda. Háček spočívá v
realizaci časového vývoje na skutečném kvantovém počítači. Mnohé členy Hamiltoniánu spolu nekomutují.
Takže zatímco některé jednoduché exponenciální operátory jako e na mocninu záporného i z odpovídají jednoduchým
circuit, obecné Hamiltoniány nikoli, a protože obsahují nekomutující členy,
nemůžeme jednoduše rozložit exponenciálu na součin jednoduchých, jako to lze s čísly. Takže
to není triviální, ale jde o dobře prostudovaný proces v kvantovém počítání. Časový vývoj
provádíme na kvantových počítačích pomocí procesu zvaného trotterizace, což je samo o sobě bohaté téma. Ale na velmi vysoké úrovni
rozdělením časového vývoje na malé kroky, řekněme M kroků, omezujeme dopady nekomutativnosti
členů. Nazvěme Krylovův podprostor řádu r, který jsme vygenerovali v klasickém kontextu pomocí mocnin h
přímo, mocninným Krylovým podprostorem kpr.
Nyní generujeme podobný prostor pomocí unitárního operátoru časového vývoje u daného exponenciálou iht.
Budeme na to odkazovat jako na unitární Krylovův prostor kur.
Mocninný Krylovův podprostor kpr, který klasicky používáme, nelze přímo generovat na kvantovém počítači, protože h
není unitární operátor. Používání unitárního Krylovova podprostoru lze ukázat jako zaručující podobnou konvergenci
jako mocninný Krylovův podprostor.
Konkrétně chyba základního stavu konverguje efektivně, pokud má počáteční stav V překryv se
skutečným základním stavem, který není exponenciálně mizivý, a pokud je dostatečná mezera mezi vlastními
stavy. Mocniny u se zde stávají různými časovými kroky. K-tá mocnina u je krokem
vpřed o čas k * dt.
Prvek podprostoru, který je časově vyvíjen po celkovou dobu kdt, můžeme označit jako s sub k. Náš
Hamiltonián H pak projektujeme na unitární Krylovův podprostor kur. Jinými slovy,
vypočítáme každý maticový prvek h v bází kur. Tuto
projektovanou matici nazveme h tilda. Maticové prvky H tildy jsou dány těmito středními hodnotami, které lze
odhadnout pomocí kvantového počítače.
Mej na paměti, že H lze zapsat jako součet Pauliho operátorů na různých qubitech a že ne všechny Pauliho operátory
lze měřit současně. Pauliho členy můžeme rozřadit do skupin komutujících členů a měřit všechny
najednou. Ale k pokrytí všech členů může být potřeba mnoho takových skupin. Počet různých komutujících skupin, do
nichž lze členy rozdělit, ngcp, se tak stává důležitým. Pokud použijeme unitární Krylovův podprostor dimenze r,
výsledná matice bude mít rozměry r * r. Pokud je r mnohem menší než n, dosáhli jsme
užitečného pokroku, a typicky je r mnohem menší než 100, což znamená, že to snadno diagonalizujeme na klasickém
počítači. Ale vzpomeň si, že s n a s m obecně nebudou ortogonální. Někdy
je možné diagonalizovat matici v neortogonální bázi. Existují však numerické a fyzikální důvody
pro předchozí přechod na ortogonální bázi. Proto řešíme zobecněný problém vlastních hodnot pomocí Gramovy matice s.
Prvek mn Gramovy matice je dán skalárním součinem s m a cn.
Jak prvky H tildy, tak S se počítají pomocí Hadamard testu.
Zobecněný problém vlastních hodnot pak má tuto podobu.
Jak bylo uvedeno výše, dimenze unitárního Krylovova podprostoru R je exponenciálně menší než naše původní
dimenze matice N. Takže tento problém hodnot je jednoduché klasicky vyřešit.
Shrnutí: začínáme s referenčním stavem, pak ho vyvíjíme po různé časové úseky, abychom vygenerovali unitární
Krylovův podprostor. Projektujeme náš Hamiltonián na tento podprostor a odhadujeme také překryvy
vektorů podprostoru. Nakonec klasicky vyřešíme nízkodimenzionální zobecněný problém hodnot. Porovnejme, co
určuje výpočetní náklady při použití Krylovovy techniky klasicky a kvantově mechanicky. Toto jsme
naznačili pro klasickou verzi a nejsou dokonalé analogie mezi klasickými a kvantovými přístupy pro všechny kroky. Ale tato tabulka shrnuje některé
škálování různých kroků pro přehled. Připomeň si, že Hamiltoniány mají obecně členy, které nelze měřit současně, protože
nekomutují. Členy Hamiltoniánu třídíme do skupin komutujících Pauliho operátorů, které lze všechny měřit současně, a může být potřeba mnoho
takových skupin, aby pokryly všechny nekomutující členy. Vytvoření H tildy na kvantovém počítači vyžaduje
samostatná měření pro každou skupinu komutujících Pauliho řetězců v Hamiltoniánu. A každé z nich vyžaduje mnoho shots. To musíme udělat pro R
na druhou různých maticových prvků odpovídajících R na druhou kombinacím různých faktorů časového vývoje.
Existují někdy způsoby, jak to zredukovat. Ale v tomto hrubém zpracování čas potřebný pro toto roste přibližně jako
počet shots krát počet skupin komutujících Pauliho členů krát r na druhou.
Prvky s musejí být odhadnuty, což roste jako počet shots
na třetí. Vidíme, že kvantová Krylovova diagonalizace může být užitečná v případech, kdy je počet komutujících Pauliho
skupin v Hamiltoniánu relativně malý.
Tato závislost škálování naznačuje některé aplikace, kde může být Krylovova metoda užitečná, a jiné, kde pravděpodobně
nebude. Některé Hamiltoniány mají vysokou složitost při mapování na qubity, zahrnující mnoho nekomutujících Pauliho řetězců,
které nelze snadno rozdělit do několika komutujících skupin.
To je často pravda u problémů kvantové chemie. Tato složitost například představuje dvě hlavní výzvy pro
kvantové počítače blízké budoucnosti. Za prvé, odhad každého prvku H tildy je výpočetně nákladný kvůli
velkému počtu členů. Za druhé, potřebné Trotterovy circuit jsou příliš hluboké. Oba tyto body
budou méně problematické, až kvantové počítače dosáhnou odolnosti vůči chybám, ale v blízké budoucnosti je třeba je brát v úvahu. I systémy s jednodušším mapováním
WEBVTT
než ty v kvantové chemii mohou narážet na stejné překážky, pokud mají Hamiltoniány příliš mnoho nekomutujících
členů. Krylovova metoda je nejužitečnější tam, kde lze Hamiltonián rozdělit do relativně mála komutujících Pauliho
skupin a kde je H snadné implementovat v Trotterových circuit. Obě tyto podmínky jsou splněny například
u mnoha mřížkových modelů zajímavých ve fyzice. KQD je zvláště užitečné, pokud je toho o základním
stavu známo velmi málo. To plyne z jeho inherentních záruk konvergence a jeho použitelnosti ve scénářích, kde
jsou alternativní metody nepoužitelné kvůli nedostatečné znalosti základního stavu.
Ačkoliv je KQD mocný nástroj, časově náročné aspekty protokolu, zejména odhad každého
prvku projektovaného Hamiltoniánu a překryv Krylovových stavů, představují příležitosti ke zlepšení.
Alternativní přístup zahrnuje aproximaci Krylovova stavu pomocí Trotterových circuit, poté vzorkování
aproximovaného stavu za účelem získání projekce na výpočetní bázi a poté projektování h na podprostor
generovaný těmito stavy výpočetní báze.
V případech, kde je to použitelné, tato metodologie known jako vzorkováním založená Krylovova kvantová diagonalizace SKQD
potenciálně nabízí výrazné snížení časových a zdrojových požadavků ve srovnání s tradičním KQD.
Integrace technik Krylovova podprostoru se vzorkovacími metodami v SKQD představuje vzrušující frontier v
kvantových algoritmech.